(inspiring music)
- [Mohamed] In my religion, if
I see somebody needs my help,
and I'm able, I must help.
[NPR Host] "Mohamed Bzeek knows that the children"
"he takes into his home are dying."
- I came to the United States in 1978.
I graduate from Utah State
as electronics engineer.
I met my wife in 1989,
and we started fostering
kids in the system.
Since 1989, about 80 kids.
I used to go to the children's hospital
and see those kids who is terminal.
The minute they're born,
they have medical problems.
They have suffering, nobody wants them.
I believe that every kid has rights
to have a place to call
home and have family.
I try to make them better life.
The daughter I have,
she is deaf and blind.
She has almost no brain.
They're expecting her, I
mean, she lives few weeks,
but now she is on seven years and a half.
I know she has a soul, she has a feeling,
so I always talk to her, no matter what.
She knows that I am with
her and that I love her.
When President Trump signed,
banning the several Muslim countries,
one of them is my country, Libya.
The LA Times, they did the article
on my story in their newspaper.
From the first day, my story went viral,
not the United States, all over the world.
- [News Anchor] "Mohamed
Bzeek has become something"
"of a local hero here in
Los Angeles recently."
(girl moaning)
- After three days, there
is somebody opened GoFundMe.
It's a trust fund for those kids.
I remodeled my house,
we're fixing the roof,
and bought generator, central
heat and air condition.
What's the most important for
me, it was their comments.
I used to spend, like, three,
four hours every night,
reading on them and cry.
So many people said, "We
love what you doing,"
"You inspire us, you changed our life."
A lot of people say that,
"I wanna adopt children."
A secondary teacher in north California,
she did this book: "Mohamed
Bzeek, Beard Full of Love."
- [Woman] "This book is dedicated"
"to Mr. Bzeek and his children."
Some of them wrote notes, some of them wrote something.
This one, she said, "You
are my hero, Mr. Bzeek."
"I love you."
"Dear Mr. Bzeek, I hope
you take care of your"
"sick children."
It's really makes me feel happy, you know?
There's always good in this
world more than bad things.
We are brothers and sisters in humanity.
Nobody wants to be alone.
We need each other.